(audience applauds)
- What more can I say?
They told me Zelenskyy would
introduce me tonight, but-
(audience laughs)
Thank God I got Bill instead.
Actually, Warren Beatty got me here.
He said, "Go there.
"I'll give you the award.
"I'll take you there.
"You won't be afraid," and
then he never called me again.
(audience laughs)
And no one else would come but Bill,
and people say, "My mother is dying.
"I don't feel well.
"I'm afraid of COVID," but
I think this is very nice.
I do believe that for this award,
you should add the words
for now at the end of it
because it's really scary if
you don't, but I want to...
I don't even know who a
lot of people are here.
Are they all ex-award winners?
Are you all guys who won awards here?
Did you just come as guests?
(audience murmurs)
I'm so thrilled.
Bill?
- You're doing great.
- Okay.
(audience laughs)
If you could only have heard Bill's speech
which I heard earlier in the car.
- It was terrible.
- Oh, come on.
It was fantastic.
It was great.
- No, it was really good,
but it was...
Well, it went on.
- He said, "Am I paying for this?"
and we laughed and laughed
and he didn't give it,
but it was a really good speech.
- Thank you.
(audience laughs)
- And so I don't know what else to say
except enjoy your food.
I'm not sure what it is.
What is it?
(audience murmurs)
Oh, really?
I didn't know.
Anyway, have a good time.
I'm gonna find my way off
the stage and thank...
Thank you for this amazingly heavy award.
(audience applauds)